how are you feeling first of all from
your fall I'm doing really well you know
I mean it's like it's annoying having
this is my right hand
it's where they did the surgery under
here I kept thinking my cast has like a
boulder in it but it's my arm is
actually kind of got a boulder in it
right there right now so it's
uncomfortable but you know it's
temporary and another month I'll have it
off man so I can't confirm you're just
like really like I always want to make
up a story like I saved a baby I I
escaped a shark I never had so much fun
actually breaking a bone before because
[Laughter]
no but I mean I was dancing with Val who
is so much fun and it was actually the
last time that I was gonna be doing the
up uptown girl was gonna be my first
dance and we had been practicing the
Rumba and at the very end of the day he
goes you know what just one for good
measure cuz tomorrow we do blocking and
stuff like that he said so let's just
run through one more uptown girl and it
was at that point that I started the
song and I was just walking by and I
caught my heel of my shoe and I fell
down exactly wrong
like I just landed exactly wrong on my
arm and the second it happened I was
like oh oh no I I think I broke it
I know I broke it I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this